so let's get the latest on our top story
today and the continuing strikes are
going on today's strike is being called
by the aslef union and I'm joined Now by
Mick Whelan who's the general secretary
so very good morning to you thanks so
much for coming in so today's action
will be the driver's sixth coordinated
uh day of strike action since last
summer have you made any progress with
either the rail companies or the
governments in that time very little
it's been a long on game process I've
attended every negotiation personally
um and I think we're as far away now as
we were at the start unfortunately there
have been some newspaper reports today
that have suggested that the government
might be on the brink of offering
workers a new pay deal the suggestion is
it would be worth around 2 000 pounds a
year have you heard anything along those
lines well it's nice that they tell the
newspapers and the media before they
tell us no the people that have actually
been in the talks
um I know obviously we don't know what
strings go with it I mean as we enter
2023 this is the fourth year without pay
rise and we'd normally we get this time
of year getting ready to go into pay
talks of 2023 and we've seen inflation
during a period of time run at 14 uh in
double digits this year so the figures
that are being spoke about don't really
put a dent in the cost of living crisis
so if that was offered to you which you
reject it I'd have to have a look at it
first I mean the idea that people float
stuff and then you're asked whether
you're accepted or not without seeing
the details and strings that go with it
it's very very difficult to come in on
how difficult do you think it is to get
public the public on board when you're
talking about pay because there might be
some people that say train drivers are
paid quite well aren't they I think
looking at some of the figures train
drivers earn an average of around 48 500
pounds starting salary is around thirty
thousand they might say nurses for
example are paid a lot less well I think
Nursery we have I believe the five
Brigade and public sectors workers I
believe that teachers and Vocational
staff should have what we have but I've
never been quite in the game of politics
and envy nobody's actually ever given us
anything over the course of
privatization we've given massive
productivity and flexibility to generate
what we've got and this idea then that
we shouldn't have a pay rise for 10
years to allow other people that are
underpaid to catch up with this is quite
not one we subscribe to what about how
these negotiations negotiations have
been carried out there are also some
suggestions around that the government
is is looking to try to strike a deal
with the rmt in that with aslef rather
in a bid to isolate the rmt have you
heard anything about that do you see I
saw it in the papers yesterday and it's
nonsense we won't do that I mean it we
have our strike and we're doing what
we're doing I've got great Praise My
comrades and colleagues in the rmt who
find an existential battle well they
want to take away 50 of people's jobs
and degrade what's left and I think if
the government gets away what it's doing
we'll be left with inherently unsafe
Railway system we'll have other problems
um our problem is that we work for 15
privatized companies that we'll strike
with today and they've done a rather
corrupt deal with the government that
won't allow pay rise to take place all
the talks take place through free
Collective bonding which they should do
but what about the government's argument
that there isn't a bottomless pet of
money they can't necessarily afford to
pay everybody who's asking for pay Rises
what they're asking for so we didn't
seek a pay rise during the pandemic and
we went to work
um during that period of time the people
we worked for made 500 million profits
um if you look at company's house and
the pay risers directors the dividends
that have been paid and profits made by
the rail operating companies it seems
that wages no longer part of their fixed
costs that they can pay a dividends
their shareholders out of the taxpayers
purse but the people actually generate
those dividends don't get a share
the frustrating time for passengers
isn't it look I'd much rather be talking
to you about a green agenda I'd like to
talk about safer Railways investment
growing Railways like a back to my day
job if I'm honest but we are where we
are and you know if we don't raise our
issues and articulate our voice no one's
listening to us I wouldn't be on here
today unless we were on strike well the
government's clearly feels that
passengers are frustrated they're
talking about new anti-strike
legislation aren't they they're talking
about minimum service guarantees there's
some suggestion around that that could
even potentially mean that strikes could
be deemed illegal if if unions refuse to
provide that minimum level of service
what do you make of those reports well
we already have the most Draconian and
authoritarian strike laws and Trade
Union laws in Europe only Lithuania had
worst and I think more recently with the
trade Union bill we actually outdid them
we have seen our counterparts in Europe
introduce minimum strike levels that are
unworkable the idea then that in
companies that don't fully employ enough
people that people could be forced come
to work when they legitimately illegally
should be on strike could be difficult
to see how it could be done but we'll
look at the detail of those laws if we
have to comply with them we will it's
more likely to lead to longer strife and
a different form of action because there
will be a knock-on effect by anything
that happens
and would you consider taking legal
action against the government if a
policy like that were to be introduced
we're currently with 11 other trade
unions taking legal action against the
last set of laws they put in place and
we would look at doing that in future as
well
looking at some of the figures they're
quite startling this week aren't they
about the amount of money that that
people are losing from the hospitality
sector for example because of rail
strikes doesn't there have to be some
sort of minimum service to allow people
to run their businesses allow people to
go to work well the real problems and
Logistics of the railways trains run
rounds to be in the right places for the
Peaks
um minimum service levels that
subsequently got negotiated on Company
by company basis when you look at
something that's complex in the
connectivity of the Railway to my mind
is unworkable and at what point does it
become unsafe what would the level be
would it be 20 with 30 was the only way
to run a safe Railway be 100 and take
away the right to strike totally what
sort of democracy we aiming for which
you see like I said is door is always
open to the negotiations when do you
next expect to have talks with the
government and with the Royal companies
I met with the transport Minister and
the rail Minister before Christmas and
they dropped me a note saying that the
real minister is now going to be
facilitating the talks I meet with the
rail Minister on Monday I'm hoping
shortly after that we get back into a
round where we had a effectual talks and
can resolve the situation you said
you're in it for Long Haul though how
long do you think this could go on well
when you're asked the question about how
long will you do something for you do to
find a resolution so it has to be long
haul it will do I was also ask the
question will there be more strikes and
I said that um we've just reinforced all
their mandates now people are saying we
should go harder and faster now we
haven't done that yet okay we'll meet
Whelan we appreciate you coming in I
imagine you're going down to the picket
line now are you I've got one or two
media things to do that I'm on the piggy
line at Houston and King cross thank you
okay thanks very much indeed for your
time